it was a really really interesting press
conference with thomas frank the
brentford head coach this morning he
started it by saying that they had a big
covert outbreak within their camp not
confirming whether it was players or
staff just saying that staff 13 people
had in the squad have tested positive an
additional four
overnight he wants this upcoming round
of premier league fixtures to be
cancelled brentford are away to
southampton
on
saturday afternoon southampton of course
playing last night away to crystal
palace but he said there's a high rise
of covid in the community and his
football camp and that he's encouraging
other premier league managers to ensure
that this round of upcoming fixtures is
cancelled he wants it cancelled for a
week and so i can get through to the
boxing day fixtures and see where we are
then but you know with over 78 000 more
cases of covid in the uk yesterday um
he's probably got quite a valid point
and what would you think the premier
league might
do he is awaiting his guidance from the
premier league and we will obviously
wait to see what they uh have said he
hasn't spoken to any other premier
league managers yet but you can with the
amount of positive uh cases in the camp
see this fixture
potentially being moved and he said that
he doesn't have enough players to fill
uh a starting 11 at southampton away on
saturday so he would look to use his
brentford b team players and would also
consider putting himself in the team
because the situation is that bad for
them
and what about um other clubs how have
they been impacted
yeah well just last night we saw
brighton lose at home to wolverhampton
and graham potter their head coach in
his post-match interview saying that he
did ask the premier league for that
fixture to be postponed just because
that they didn't have um enough
first-team players to play against
wolves we've also seen other managers
like dean smith at norwich saying that
he wants clarification from the premier
league as to how many players they need
in a squad before uh fix you can go
ahead and how many players they can have
unavailable before a match does get
postponed
okay good to talk to you
just let me ask you before you go when
will we know whether they're going to
postpone or not
uh to be honest the time we found out um
matches have been postponed have been up
until a couple of hours beforehand but
we are expecting an update from the
premier league later today informing us
about this upcoming round of premier
league fixtures